[Musique]
oh
il était une fois une fille adorée de
tous qui vivaient dans une source
et puis un jour le curé fille dressé en
cet endroit une grande croix de pierre
pendant 15 cents en plus de personne
n'entendit parler de la fait même les
curés cessèrent de croire en elle
patience un jour cette croix tombera et
de nouveaux jets serait libre un jour
deux hommes passèrent près de la source
ils décidèrent de l'utiliser pour le
ravitaillement de l'air
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'a fait se retrouve à
un beau jour dans une canalisation
aboutissant à un robinet cuivre d'une
famille ouvrière comprenant le père la
mère et deux grandes filles une fois
l'aînée des filles qui étaient gourmande
et mal élevés se leva sur le coup de 2
heures du matin pour aller tremper son
doigt dans un pot de confiture et le les
chats après quoi elle eu soif
mais voilà qu'au lieu de dos il
s'échappa du rebut une toute petite
bonne femme avec des m2 ligne bonjour
martel madame veux tu être gentille
martin de moi un peu de confiture
quand elle vit que la fée était bien
habillé avec des ailes de libellule et
une baguette magique lui dit et
certainement madame en remercie martine
je vais te faire un don à chaque mot que
tu diras il te sortira de la bouche
une perle ben ça alors
si elle disait des mots bull ont un gros
tir est peut-être
mon rôle
10 constitutionnel les pères n'en furent
pas plus grosse mais plus allongée et
d'une forme plus biscornues en pis le
tout face sur l'autre fortune effet geek
oui
c'est tout
alors les parents obligèrent martin à ne
plus dire que des gros mots au dessus du
saladier
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
on
allez encore vous êtes merveilleuse
restons ensemble
voulez vous nous serons heureux
maintenant matip parlant de choses
sérieuses ce soit quand je reviendrai je
veux que la grande soupe hier je vois
plein de grosses perles
[Musique]
la jeune soeur de martin qui était sage
et bonne n'avait pas la moindre envie de
rencontrer la fée du robinet je n'irai
pas dans la cuisine je n'irai pas dans
la cuisine et repas dans la cuisine
pour finir il ya là en espérant que la
fin ne sortirait pas toi qui est bonne
donne moi un peu de confiture
merci bien je n'ai pas besoin de vos
dons
vous avez fait le malheur de ma soeur
est bien puisque vous êtes si peu
aimables je vous donne pour donc à
chaque mot que vous direz il vous
sortira de la bouche un serpent
[Musique]
[Rires]
voulez-vous me suivre dans la salle de
bain mangez-vous bien sûr la baignoire
et maintenant petit hameau maman à
présent la petite marie dites moi une
paroles méchantes h
que faut-il faire docteur mon cher
monsieur
j'ai bien l'honneur de vous demander la
main de votre fille
c'est ainsi que marie épousa le jeune
médecin qui travaille à l'institut
pasteur à la fabrication des sérums
antivenimeux ce dernier fut très bon
pour elle à quelque temps de là la fée
du robinet voulu savoir ce qu'il était
advenu des deux filles est elle apparue
à leurs parents elle les interrogeaient
les parents la myrte au courant la
pauvre fait découragés se dit en
elle-même il faut que je trouve un
enchanteur plus sage que man la fée du
robinet dessina donc un enchanteur
a pourvu qu'ils l'aiment et elle se mit
de côté acheteur plus couleur des yeux
je t'ai dessinée veux tu met d'accord
avant tout je vais ôter leurs dons à
marie ainsi qu'à martin le lendemain
martin avait cessé de cracher des perles
et le jeune homme à l'air doux la chasse
a alors elle revint chez ses parents et
fut désormais douce est bonne le même
jour marie cessa de cracher des serpents
l'enchanteur l à fait disparu
ils ne font presque plus de miracles ils
sont très très prudent